visually they make a lot of tires but
did you know Mishler also makes a
michelang guide the most prestigious
restaurant and book in the world
so I did a French Tire company goes from
Cars to Cuisine the year is 1889. the
car was freshly invented and two French
Brothers Andre
and eduard I just opened a tire company
the only problem if you rent many cars
there were only three thousand in all of
France so the brothers cried their heads
and sort of ways to convince people to
buy cars and therefore their tires they
thought and they thought and they
thought a bit more when ban an ingenious
ideas truck the process would create a
free guide with all the best hotels
mechanics gas stations and of course
restaurants so that everyone would want
to buy a car and explore France soon 35
000 copies were making their way across
France and further versions were being
made for Germany Spain and Northern
Africa although readers were grateful
for least of nearby gas stations what
they really loved was a restaurant
section and they wanted to know which
ones were best so the brothers sent
secret inspectors to visit and review
restaurants Michela aspects would then
judge the restaurants on five rooms
quality of products personality of the
chef represented in the dish value for
money consistency and Mastery of flavor
and cooking technique fast forward to
1926 and the first Michelin star ratings
were given to fine dining establishments
I miss you may I please press on the
Michelin star system in trevantage
category one star a very good restaurant
in category
two stars excellent cooking was a detour
in the mayor tablet Voyage three stars
exceptional Cuisine was a special
Journey today the guide rates over 40
000 establishments in over 24
territories across three continents
while Michener sells 200 million tires a
year that's a whole lot of tires
foreign